How does the Witness Protection Program Work?
Born of the Organized Crime Control Act of
1970, and the brainchild of longtime Department
of Justice attorney, Gerald Shur, the U.S.
Marshall Service Witness Security Program
(WITSEC) has successfully protected more than
18,000 people since it first began operations
in 1971.
Membership in the witness protection program
is typically for life, and usually begins
with a visit from U.S. marshals, whether anticipated
or not.
While many of the witnesses and their family
members have time to make the decision and
prepare for their new lives, others are forced
to choose rather quickly.
Even occasionally having to leave within moments
of the marshals arriving.
Family members also join, and typically this
includes a spouse and children, although sometimes
even mistresses have been protected.
And, since the program requires that all participants
leave everything behind – including parents,
siblings, assets and identity – innocent
family members and informants alike are faced
with an impossible decision: join the program
and lose your “life,” or stay and potentially
lose your life.
Relocation sites are chosen by WITSEC marshals,
although families are allowed to choose from
several options.
The location ultimately chosen is then disclosed
to only a few people within the program.
Before beginning their new lives, family members
are given new identities.
One woman, Jackee Taylor (née Jacqueline
Crouch), who was 7 when her family entered
the program in 1981, later remembered spending
hours practicing writing her new name while
waiting to be placed.
Once a witness has finished testifying, the
family is transported to the new location
where they are often put up in a hotel until
a suitable home is chosen.
Relocated families receive a monthly stipend,
along with money for housing and other expenses
that are eventually phased out after the adults
have had enough time to find new means of
supporting themselves.
Early on when the program was being developed,
many things fell through the cracks.
WITSEC marshals often either had to forge
documents or simply failed to provide them
for everyone; for example, Jackee Taylor was
never given a birth certificate nor, obviously,
is she able to get one from anywhere.
So when she was little, she couldn’t play
softball, and later in life, she had a difficult
time enrolling in college and getting married.
In addition, although today there are set
limits for expenses, that policy only came
about after some serious growing pains.
For example, after the acting head of the
Los Angeles crime syndicate, Aladena Jimmy
“The Weasel” Fratianno, turned informant
in 1978, he was paid nearly $1,000,000 over
the next 10 years while in the program.
Perhaps worth it, Fratianno’s testimony
ultimately helped to convict more than 2 dozen
gangsters; on the other hand, in addition
to paying for food, housing, living expenses
and health care, WITSEC was also paying for
unnecessary expenses including Fratianno’s
wife’s plastic surgery and even a monthly
stipend for her mother.
So, in 1987 when Fratianno’s information
dried up, so did the government’s patience,
and WITSEC cut off his income and stopped
providing 24/7 protection.
Although Fratianno claimed to fear for his
life afterward, he lived for another 6 years
and died in his sleep in 1993.
Today most of the bugs have been worked out,
and legally sealed name changes, new social
security cards, birth certificates and drivers’
licenses are all routinely issued; in addition,
medical and school records are quickly transferred
and fake credit histories are created.
In sum, since 1971, about 8,500 witnesses
and 9,900 family members have been protected
by WITSEC, and no one who has followed the
program’s guidelines has ever been killed.
However, not everyone successfully transitions
into the program.
In 1980, Henry Hill testified against his
former associates in the Lucchese crime family,
and was placed in witness protection along
with his wife and two kids.
Having difficulty adjusting, the Henry Hill’s
(changed to the Martin Lewis’s and later
the Peter Haines’s) had to be relocated
10 times from places including Independence,
Kentucky; Redmond, Washington; and Omaha,
Nebraska.
Bored to tears, Henry (or Martin or Peter)
continued with his criminal activities and
during the 1980s was arrested for crimes ranging
from assault to drunk driving to burglary.
In 1985, he outed himself a bit when he worked
with Nicholas Pileggi to write his memoir,
Wiseguy, which became the 1990s Goodfellas.
Shortly thereafter, in 1987, Henry/Martin/Peter
was arrested for trying to sell a pound of
cocaine to two DEA agents, which ultimately
resulted in his expulsion from the program.
Apparently, however, exile didn’t cause
him too many problems with those he’d testified
against, since Henry lived to 2012, dying
of
a heart attack.